there was only one finale the crowds had
wanted
and they got it
[Applause]
the queen stepping out once again
her heirs alongside her for a moment
that even for them was breathtaking
a snapshot of the future on the palace
balcony that's been such a focal point
of so many milestones of the past 70
years
[Music]
[Applause]
they started the pageant by taking us
back the centerpiece the gold state
coach she used in 1953
the young monarch once again projected
inside bringing the coronation to life
for a new audience
behind the perfect military pageantry a
distinctly british display
something for everyone whatever your age
a nostalgic carnival of buses and music
and even the royal family were hooked
the younger ones at times were a little
restless but generally on best behavior
as the procession passed by
an introduction to the kind of things
you're expected to do when you're a
royal
but also they were doing it their own
way a video posted on social media
showed cakes they'd made and sent to a
street party in cardiff grandad prince
charles and camilla hosted the flagship
big lunch at the oval cricket ground in
london to her majesty the queen
this creation made out of felt not ideal
if they were peckish but others just
loving the chance to get together and
it's just amazing to hear all the
fantastic things that that are going on
within our communities the lunch was
brilliant
this is like a lifetime something which
i will never forget it was a great day
to be
out here celebrating a big lunch and
yeah just i love the cake decorations
that i've been around prince edward and
sophie joined one virtually in the
queen's back garden on the long walk in
windsor
it produced what will be iconic pictures
of these celebrations
a weekend where the queen has shown us
her faith in her family and encouraged
us to believe in them too
always with one eye on the future she's
once again made history after a
spectacular
70 years as queen
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace